bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
petite foire aux questions cette petite
interview aujourd'hui en compagnie de
cécile cournède cécile bonjour donc
cécile tué géologue spécialisée dans le
magnétisme extraterrestres à minneapolis
aux états unis et tu viens de participer
à la publication d'un article très
intéressant sur le débat sur la question
de l'impact ou du volcanisme lors de la
crise crétacé paléogène donc la fameuse
crise qui a vu l'extinction des
dinosaures d'un d'une grande partie de
la faune marine bref la cinquième des
grosses des grosses d'extinction des
plus grosses d'extinction que notre
terre est connue donc dans cet article
alors cet article vous vous n'avez
peut-être pas vu passer l'article
original qui est sorti dans silent mais
vous avez certainement vu passer des
coupures de presse qui disait que le
débat finalement été réglé entre entre
volcanisme et impacts météoritiques et
justement c'est ce dont on va discuter
aujourd'hui avec cécile qui faisait donc
partie des auteurs de cet article donc
on prend nos informations directement à
la source
voilà donc la première question que
j'aimerais te poses et cécile s'est déjà
bains où en était le débat finalement
quand vous avez commencé à travailler
sur ce sujet sur la question le problème
majeur en fait c'est que la question
était toujours d'actualité puisque les
questions de timing ce taser quand a eu
lieu
quoi et que sont les effets de chaque
événement déjà de parts individuelles
donc quels sont les effets de l'impact
en lui même à court terme à long terme
quels sont les effets d'un volcan du
volcanisme à court terme à long terme de
savoir aussi en terme donc toujours de
timing au niveau du volcanisme est ce
que ça a eu lieu en une seule fois
est-ce que ça a eu lieu en plusieurs
fois est ce que ça a eu lieu un peu
avant l'impact
un peu après toutes ces questions là en
fait ça n'a jamais été vraiment résolu
puisque du coup ça dépend beaucoup de
qu'est ce qu'on met dans les modèles
pour faire tourner pour savoir ce qu'on
obtient comme résultat et donc les
modèles dépendent de tous ces paramètres
qui sont qui peuvent être très variables
en fait donc
donc ça c'est là c'est là que c'est là
que c'est la réponse très technique
j'avoue j'avoue mais j'avoue mon
ignorance totale sur le sujet voilà il
faut que je le dise si tu veux on va
peut-être partir de là où moi j'en étais
resté j'imagine que c'est là où tout le
monde en était en était resté enfin la
plupart des gens qui nous écoutent en
était resté en gros moi ce que je veux
ce que je me disais c'était que le débat
il était un peu clos dans le sens où il
ya une espèce de consensus mou qui
s'était installé entre c'est un petit
peu du volcanisme c'est beaucoup de la
météorite et que les deux ont
certainement interagit dans le sens où
la météorite accélérer le volcanisme
donc ça jusqu'à quel point c'est jusqu'à
quel point ces valide en fait cette
espèce de d'image que populaire qu on
est de suite d'événements je dirais que
c'est toujours valide en fait en
quelques sortes
parce que c'est à dire que déjà ça s'est
passé il ya 65 millions d'années donc de
par une viste de par la date on a
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur qu'est ce
qui s'est réellement passé cette époque
là du coup pour justement arrivé à
savoir quoi a eu lieu quand en si peu de
temps
ben on a faim c'est très on peut très
rapidement se dire que c'est un effet
combiné des deux qui a qui a conduit à
l'extinction de masse
à ce moment là quoi on va voir que à
l'issue de cet article finalement elle
la réponse sera que le suspense a laissé
cet article la réponse est toujours la
même qu'avant en fait c'est un peu une
combinaison des deux si on considère
la chose dans son ensemble après je
regarde dans le détail on se rend compte
que c'est l'impact qui a créé
l'inspection des espèces vivantes
d'accord bas du cou plongeon dans les
détails et sur ce que l'article apporte
ce que c'est un article alors c'est un
article qui est qui est très détaillé
qui est très géologique
donc du coup c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment pas facile à lire si vous
n'avez pas solide
un solide background géologique quoi
donc
est ce que tu pourrais nous nous
expliquer ça dans on va dire détaillé
mais de façon accessible un peu plus
accessible oui alors donc déjà dans
l'article ce qui a été fait c'est une
reconstruction des températures les
variations de température au moment de
la crise crétacé tertiaire et on a
comparé donc c'est un relevé température
obtenu grâce aux carottes de sédiments à
des modèles des modèles cinq modèles on
va dire and members donc c'est à dire
avec des conditions vraiment extrêmes
donc ces cinq modèles
on les a fait tourner avec donc
différents paramètres et on les a
comparées avec les données obtenues dans
les carottes et ensuite par comparaison
on arrive à savoir c'est comme ça en
plus ou moins qu il déduit qui est
déduit dans l'article shell paramètres
enfin a permis de reconstruire les
données qu'on a dans les carottes et du
coup grâce à sa bande ont déduit que ça
s'est passé d'une telle façon plutôt que
dit notre d'accord et donc ça ça
reconstruit en fait une série
d'événements d'après les températures
c'est ça c'est ça d'accord et cette
série d'événements en fait on voit
qu'elle s'accélère avec un impact
météoritique pas avec le volcanisme est
ce que c'est bien ça est ce que je
comprends bien ou alors du coup quand on
compare par rapport à ce poser est donc
ce qu'on fait donc c'est qu'on fait
d'abord ceux relevés de température dans
les carottes grâce au dioxyde de carbone
et aussi au delta ses treize donc le
ratio donc c'est un rapport isotopique
en 3 le carbone 13 et le carbone 12 nous
sachant que là les organismes capte prix
fernand préférentiellement le carbone 12
août et y aura plus d'activités
biologique
ça va faire diminuer le delta ses treize
donc en parallèle ce qu'ils ont fait ce
qu'on a fait
même si j'ai pas comment participer à la
réalisation des modèles c'est que on a
fait tourner cinq scénarios dans
lesquels pour le premier par exemple on
en voit tant de pourcentage de gaz due
aux éruptions
ensuite on crée l'impact et ensuite on
en voit encore du gaz des laves à cause
de l'éruption et on voit les effets de
la température des variations de carbone
du coup avec ces événements là sur un
autre sur un autre scénario par exemple
on va faire le dégazage et l'éruption
entièrement avant de faire l'impact ou
bien tout en même temps et donc ça va
créer des profils de variations selon
les scénarios qui en suit donc vos
corrélés ou pas avec ce qu'on a obtenu
dans les carottes de sédiments d'accord
donc d'après les carottes vous avez un
scénario de variations de température
voilà que vous avez donc une
augmentation de température juste avant
la crise kpmg et ensuite une on va dire
une petite enfin donc ça revient au
niveau avoue d'avant au moment de la
crise et ensuite ça refait un petit bump
une petite augmentation ou diminution
c'est avec ça qu'on va essayer de faire
coller les scénarios d'accord c'est le
seul paramètre que vous avez regardé la
température où il y en a d'autres
donc en gros en gros c'est surtout la
température
et le cycle du carbone et du coup un
cycle du carbone s'ils redondant avec la
température quoi un passé et c'est
corrélés directement ouais d'accord
donc vous avez vous avez ce qui s'est
passé au niveau de la température au
niveau de la carotte et vous avez mode
et enfin et donc tes collègues ont
modélisé en parallèle plusieurs
scénarios virtuel complètement virtuel
pour voir lequel collet mieux à ce qu'il
s'est réellement passé en fait tout à
fait en sachant que les scénarios en
fait ils ont exactement les mêmes
conditions
les seuls paramètres qui change c'est
quand est ce qu'on n'en voit les gaz le
dégazage du volcanisme d'être apps est
ce qu'on le fait entièrement avant est
ce qu'on en fait un peu avant un peu
après l'heure l'impact est ce qu'on en
fait tout au long de l'impact fin enfin
pas tout on n'a pas toujours la période
même l'impact ou est-ce qu'on fait tout
après et donc voilà quels sont les
écueils en fait dans le détail ce qui se
passe c'est que par exemple le
volcanisme va au moment du dégazage
relâcher des futurs du chlore du carbone
du dioxyde de carbone et donc tous et
tous ces éléments là ont des effets
différents au niveau environnemental
dont par exemple les succursales a
montré une acidification des océans le
carbone ça va entraîner un réchauffement
climatique et en parallèle donc l'impact
lui va aussi avoir différents effets
donc à court terme par exemple en termes
de jours
quelques jours ça va entraîner une forte
chaleur au départ après plusieurs jours
et plusieurs années ça va entraîner nous
une acidification des océans et si on
regarde a pris plusieurs dizaines
d'années ça va même entraîner un
refroidissement ou finale puisque
les poussières les aérosols voix en
faire un appel un hiver ça va couvrir
toute la la terre et du coup ça m'a
empêché les gens du soleil d'accéder la
surface
du coup ce qui peut arriver en fait
c'est que les effets combinés des deux
ça nulle en quelque sorte
donc selon qu'on en place l'un et
l'autre bas on n'aura pas du tout les
mêmes réponses au niveau climatique et
biologiques
donc au final on a ces différents
scénarios avec tous ces paramètres qui
sont pris en compte
et du coup celui qui colle le mieux
c'est suspense c'est ce mais surtout
celui où on a du dégazage avant l'impact
donc qui crée cette petite augmentation
de température qu'on voit juste avant
l'impact
et on en a aussi un petit peu après au
final qui permet en fait de meetings et
de deux compenser voilà compenser merci
un petit peu en fait les effets de
l'impact lui-même et qui en fait en
quelques sortes les deux associés aide à
recréer en fait la relancer la
productivité ensuite biologique sur
terre alors attends si je comprends bien
ça veut dire que le volcanisme
il a aidé la vie à reprendre après
l'impact
en quelque sorte si j'ai bien compris ce
qui se passe à la fin
oui encore lui alors après du coup ce
qu'on dit c'est surtout ce qui le plus
important du coup c'est que quand on
regarde les foraminifères donc les
petits organismes marins dans les
carottes donc on voit une disparition
totale de tout ça au moment de la
transition au moment de l'impact donc
c'est là qu'on me dit que c'est
entièrement à cause de l'impact qui a
une disparition de la vie est par contre
après donc les variations de carbone de
ça va dépendre d'eux coupé oui mais
parce que les dinosaures et pile c'est
finalement c'est qu'une partie assez
négligeable de la biodiversité c'est
surtout les forums
enfin les foraminifères sont en nombre
en majorité écrasante
d'accord d'accord donc donc le scénario
qui colle le mieux c'est celui où
l'impact finalement l'effet le plus
important ce pardon c'est ceux où
l'impact à l'effet le plus important
ouais c'est ça ouais donc toi dans tout
ça ta contribution parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'auteurs et des fois
tu parle même d autres auteurs à la
troisième personne donc du coup ça me
conduit vers cette question toi ta
contribution spécifique à cet article ça
a était quoi alors en étant spécialiste
du magnétisme extra terrestre je n'ai
pas vraiment travaillé sur l'impact en
lui-même
même si j'aurais bien aimé j'ai
travaillé sur la reconstruction
paléomagnétiques de la carotte
ça consiste en fait à retrouver
l'histoire magnétique des sédiments et
donc à retracer je ne sais pas si cette
famille avec ça en gros à savoir quand
est-ce qu'ils avaient lieu les ont hués
de l'inversion magnétique
c'est à dire qu'on regarde c'est ça se
représente par une petite flèche ou bien
la petite flèche elle pointe comme ça ou
bien une pointe comme ça donc soit le
pôle nord magnétique est aligné avec le
pôle nord géographique soit le pôle nord
magnétique qui aligne avec le pôle sud
géographique
donc on parle de talent vers ce normal
un garçon normal et donc c'est ça qu'on
voit des fois sur le pouvoir des fois
sur les articles des bandes blanches et
des bandes noires en alternance qu'on
appelle des crown et donc c'est ça que
j'ai fait pour cet article
la reconstruction paléomagnétiques ça
apporte quoi en fait apporte une
contrainte temporelle du coup rapport à
d'autres d'autres paramètres qui
permettent aussi d'effectuer des des
datations parce que ce que la crise
crétacé paléogène et elle est corrélée
avec une aversion de champs magnétiques
c'est ça le numéro 29 financer sa bat
pas vraiment
elle a lieu pendant une période une
période inverse un inverseur pendant une
période
ok donc les inversions de champs
magnétiques rassurez vous ça pas tant
d'effet que ça au final non mais quand
même avec des actions de masse mais bon
il y en a toujours qui essaie il y en a
pas il n'y a pas vraiment de relation
mais je pense qu'on serait quand même
embêté si c'est à vue du moment
voilà surtout si on est un pigeon
voyageur je suppose d'accord ok abba
note notre dernière question
traditionnelle
c est ce qu il ya quelque chose que tu
tiens à dire quelque chose qui te tient
à coeur par rapport évidemment à la
thématique dont on est en train de
parler que tu souhaiterais présenter
alors si je devais dire quelque chose
qui me tient à coeur
comme je dis à tous mes étudiants quand
je quand j'enseigne ces consciences
rien n'est sûr et que enfin pas rien
parce que la terre est ronde
je pense mais globalement on peut il ya
beaucoup de domaines et beaucoup de
sujets qui qui sont incompris même si on
pense qu'en fait on sait on sait déjà ce
qui se passait beaucoup de questions
encore à un raid de problèmes à résoudre
et de questions auxquelles il faut
répondre et pendant en termes d'audience
ce qui répond à notre question du début
faut-il croire les médias qui nous
annoncent la fin du débat la réponse est
non d'accord et ben merci beaucoup de
nous avoir accordé de ton temps pour
répondre à ces questions
j'espère j'espère que tu re publiera
encore beaucoup d'articles intéressants
comme celui là et que et contre vera et
qu'on te reverra bientôt pour de futures
découvertes et puis et puis à tout le
monde et bien je dis merci à tous et à
une prochaine fois sur notre chaîne à
bas
[Musique]